-Guys, we have
exactly six shows left before
we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Six days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a stunning
Christmas sweater from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Now, since there are
six shows left,
let's open door number 6.
[ Drumroll ]
Whenever you're ready.
Alright.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't understand.
I don't quite -- Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Oh, and it -- Turn it.
So, it comes
with a hat on the back.
-Whoo!
-You can't wear it.
You can't wear it.
It's stuck to the sweater.
-Mm-hmm.
-Interesting. That's an
interesting way to do it.
Now let's see who's going to go
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest,
can I get a drumroll, please?
Who wants this great sweater?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on down!
Yes, come over here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome!
Thank you so much
for being here.
This is it.
What is your name?
-Tori.
-Tori, where are you from?
-I'm from Boston.
-From Boston! We love Boston!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It does get
a little chilly in Boston,
so this will go perfect.
Are you a cow-- Do you like
country and being a cowboy?
-I guess I do now.
-Yes, of course.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's yours now.
Would you like to try it on?
We'd love to, yeah.
I think there might be
one more button.
-Yeah, one more button.
-I think this is
going to be great.
You can't wear the hat.
No, the hat is just decoration.
You don't wear the hat.
Oh, whoa, whoa. This is subtle.
Are you kidding me?
Are you joking?
That is phenomenal.
Look at that!
Look at that hat on the back.
That's unbelievable.
It looks gorgeous.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations.
Give her a
round of applause, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]